would you rather
spend the rest of your life with someone
you don't like that much
or be lonely
I I take
the companions
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
sorry like I think I also think that's a
problem with modern women
that's not me but um you know I think I
would compensate like every other woman
that's out there
friends you know what I mean
brunches
really I think I would rather not be in
a relationship with somebody
[Music]
you don't have to be
actually great so I've been traveling I
mean so I would rather go if I had to
choose
having great experiences rather than
being shocked up or something
yes
three quarters of suicide environment a
lot of the time that they're doing that
because they don't have an outlet
so so when you say that I think
very disappointed
you really talk to you
try and ask people
[Music]
started
but most of the people just come yeah
I had a lot of friends that killed
himself
[Music]
sorry because um
foreign
because we need to look sexually you
know and especially if you
if you say a street or another class
she doesn't want to you know discover
different kind of society
it would be more money
you know but then that's what's
happening like most men
think
major
like I was watching this
in school shoes
dude it doesn't have much of a social
life
can't really enter socially and awkward
right and all of these things are
pilot
see
so they do these
random things
so when I was asking about like who
deals with loneliness like
I would say seems women are dealing with
it now I don't think they like it as
much but they're less likely to
tend to disagree
even though you're right about
I also think that like
well actually a Mormon fact but in this
context but no I've noticed that there's
a lot of lonely men out there they still
manage to be afully employed
they will find something to do to fill
their day and I think like with women if
there's only they can
they can't cope they have to continue to
Vibe for male attention or get a group
of girlfriends but I've just I've seen a
lot of you know quote-unquote lonely men
they can throw themselves into their
work and even if they're not passionate
I don't know why but that's my
perspective on why I disagree and why I
think men can
only hold the lonely old man not what I
preferred that you know if men could be
married to like some feminine women have
a legacy yes but you know I've seen
women who were by themselves and as long
as you're living
life
you've got you know some
set out to do
we'd be running Ultra marathons you can
be doing like the cross-country RV and I
think you'll be okay but women I think
it drives them insane we'll put it this
way
hypothetical guy
to be that guys
see myself could you could you could we
imagine a female
like self-employed I mean they will also
like Xbox no they'll just like gain a
bunch of weight and
your girlfriends and five reasons
women don't get a true chance to be
lonely until
then
[Music]
um
after 50
in the government
I got children now
ready connection they ended up lonely
bye guys
because people my age
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible